Je peux le faire ! Je peux le faire ! Je peux
le faire…
Putain mais j’en étais sûr ! C’est du
mytho aussi !
C’est pas vrai !
Poudlard mon cul ouais
!
Poudlard my ass !
Wow
Hurt ? Ah the song from Christina Aguilera
?
J’ai un problème avec la France.
Les gens critiquent Cyril Hanouna mais regardent
son émission.
Thank you London.
Je voulais passer chez Sosh…
French kiss ? French kiss ? Non c’est la
bouche.
Non ? Alright
Oh non !! Can you help me to ramasse my tea
?
Là j’ai un début de désir, j’ai 5%
de désir.
Bah faudra pas s’étonner s’il y a une
nouvelle Jeanne D’Arc qui débarque.
Si on reste près, tu peux sentir ma gaule.
D’accord.
L’autre jour j’ai vu plus con que moi,
j’ai vu un canard se prendre un panneau.
Maybe I need some help but it's ok, I was a
duck.
Goodbye sir.
J’ai j’ai j’ai j’ai j’ai !
J’ai rien compris.